(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
I.S.I.S. THERE.
I GUESS THERE'S REALLY NOTHING
ELSE ANYBODY'S REALLY TALKING
ABOUT ON EVERY CHANNEL IN THE
KNOWN UNIVERSE.
>> THE WORLD IS GETTING TO KNOW
CAITLYN JENNER THIS MORNING.
>> CAITLYN JENNER STEPPING OUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
CALL HER CAITLYN.
>> STORY OF THE DAY, BRUCE
JENNER --
>> CAITLIY JENNER MADE HER
DEBUT --
>> CAITLYN JENNER...
>> Jon: PRETTY SURE THAT NEWS
ANCHOR JUST ASKED IF CAITLYN
JENNER KNOWS WHERE THE LIBRARY
IS.
MY SPANISH ISN'T GREAT.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS TREMENDOUS.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S ESPECIALLY BRAVE
OF CAITLIN JENNER TO DO THIS
PUBLICLY BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THE
MEDIA -- THEY'RE AWFUL.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
LISTEN TO A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING
AWFUL THINGS ABOUT THIS.
>> A BRAVE OLYMPIAN TRANSFORMED.
IT'S REALLY QUITE INSPIRING.
VERY INSPIRATIONAL.
I THINK IT'S COURAGEOUS.
T SENDS A MESSAGE TO THE
WORLD THIS IS WHO I AM.
>> I THINK IT'S A REALLY HEALTHY
THING TO TALK ABOUT.
>> AN IMPORTANT
CULTURAL MILESTONE.
A BIG MOMENT FOR CAITLIN
JENNER, AND SOCIETY.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT...
THAT WAS ACTUALLY GREAT.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, SOME PEOPLE
WERE DICKS BUT, YOU KNOW --
(LAUGHTER)
-- TODAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO LET
THEM RUIN IT.
IT'S HEARTENING TO SEE EVERYONE
IS NOT ONLY ACCEPTING CAITLIN
JENNER AS A WOMAN BUT WASTE
NO TIME IN TREATING HER AS A
WOMAN.
>> WOW.
SEXY.
I GOT A COUPLE OF E-MAILS FROM A
FRIEND SAYING I'M A LITTLE
JEALOUS, SHE LOOKS BETTER THAN I
DO.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE A MOVIE STAR.
RITA HAYWORTH,
SO GLAMOROUS.
>> LOOKS STUNNING.
AMAZING.
YES!
CAITLIN IS HOT!
YEAH, SEXY BOOBS!
>> Jon: I MEAN, I WAS, LIKE,
MY BRAIN WAS, LIKE, THIS IS A
GREAT MILESTONE FOR THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY BUT MY
PENIS WAS ALL, LIKE, (BLEEP)!
(APPLAUSE)
YOU SEE, CAITLIN, WHEN YOU WERE
A MAN, WE COULD TALK ABOUT YOUR
ATHLETICISM, YOUR BUSINESS
ACUMEN, BUT NOW YOU'RE A WOMAN
AND YOUR LOOKS ARE REALLY THE
ONLY THING WE CARE ABOUT.
WHICH BRINGS US TO PHASE TWO OF
YOUR TRANSITION -- COMPARATIVE
(BLEEP)ABILITY.
>> IT'S LIKE THAT CHICK FROM
AMERICAN HORROR STORY.
>> JESSICA LANGE.
CAITLIN IS HOTTER THAN CHRIS.
DOES SHE HAVE A BETTER BODY
THAN KIM KARDASHIAN?
>> LOOK...
WE WANT TO GIVE A WOMAN A
COMPLIMENT HERE, WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE ANOTHER WOMAN GETS
TAKEN DOWN A BIT IN THE PROCESS
IT'S HOW WE MAINTAIN THE
BALANCE.
WELL, WE'RE ALMOST ALL THE WAY
THERE.
LET'S COMPLETE THE TRANSITION.
>> SHE LOOKS GOOD.
ESPECIALLY FOR HER AGE.
>> Jon: THERE YOU GO!
WOW!
THAT'S THE CAVEAT WE WERE
MISSING, REMINDER HER SHE HAS AN
EXPIRATION DATE NOW!
YOU CAME OUT AT 65, YOU'VE GOT
ANOTHER TWO YEARS BEFORE YOU
BECOME INVISIBLE TO SOCIETY!
BETTER MAKE THE MOST OF THEM.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? SINCE IT'S A
SPECIAL DAY, WHY
DON'T WE THROW IN A LITTLE
SLUT-SHAMING WITH A DASH OF
SHE'S PROBABLY NOT THAT HOT IN
PERSON.
>> THE OUTFIT, IT'S A WHITE
SATIN CORSET, VERY PLAYBOY
BUNNIESQUE.
>> IT SHOWS THE AMAZING EFFECT
THE MAKEUP CAN HAVE.
>> I'M WONDERING HOW MUCH IS
PHOTO SHOPPED AND AIR BRUSHED.
>> Jon: YOU TAKE AWAY THE
CORSET AND MAKEUP AND I DON'T
KNOW IF ANYONE WANTS TO BANG
HER!
(LAUGHTER)
CAITLIN JENNER, CONGRATULATIONS
WELCOME TO BEING A WOMAN IN
AMERICA.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)